-Mike, you're a nice guy.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you very much.
But not everyone is
as nice as you.
-That's true.
-I think it's important
to let the audience know
who's being nice
and who's being not nice
in our very first desk piece,
called "Nice! Not Nice!"
-♪ ♪
-(applause, whooping, cheering)
Nice!
Marine Le Pen.
She's French, she's blonde,
and she hates Muslims.
She's a triple threat.
Not nice!
-Marine World.
-Mm.
The whales are sixes,
the dolphins are fours,
and the only tens
are the penguins--
-and they're all married!
-Mm-hmm. Tough.
Nice.
My lovely daughter, Ivanka.
Her skin is like Italian marble,
and her hair is like...
really great hair.
I don't know.
Not nice!
The German people who booed her
when she defended me
at a conference in Berlin.
Disgusting!
This is the worst thing
the Germans have ever done.
Ever.
Ever, Mike. Ever.
Well...
Nice.
Clam chowder.
Thick, creamy, hot.
I could drink it with a straw.
Not nice!
Corn chowder.
It's fake chowder.
Fake chowder.
You're taking jobs away
from hardworking clams.
This American "cornage"
ends now.
(applause, whooping)
I'm gonna mix it up.
I'm gonna mix it up, Mike.
-Oh, okay.
-I'm gonna mix it up.
Are you ready? Are you ready?
-I'm-I'm Ready Freddy.
-We're mixing it up.
-Ready Freddy.
-Not nice!
Press Secretary Sean Spicer.
-(ooh'ing and oh'ing)
-He's a muttering slobbermouth
with a taste for his own foot.
Why... why don't I fire
this guy?
Nice.
Sean Spicer's TV ratings--
I can't fire this guy.
His ratings are tremendous.
We love ratings,
and Spicer brings 'em in.